El resultado de la votación ha sido el siguiente,
votos emitidos, 344 son las 2, sí, 312,
no 32, la 1 en Canarias.
En consecuencia,
queda aprobada la propuesta
de reforma del artículo 49 de la constitución.
Aprobada
la reforma que VA a eliminar el término disminuido
de la Constitución española
y lo primero que debemos hacer
es pedir disculpas
a las personas
a las que nuestra constitución se refirió
con 1 término tan ofensivo durante tantos años.
Las palabras importan porque definen nuestra visión
del Mundo. Y es que las personas con discapacidad son,
sobre todo personas y como tales,
sujetos de derechos.
Pedro Sánchez ha sido el encargado de cerrar la sesión
1, votación en la que Vox ha votado finalmente
no a la reforma de ese artículo 49.
Lo ha hecho con 1 argumento tan sólido
como que vota no por no votar
junto al PP y al gobierno.
Política de altos vuelos
hora 14
Javier Casal